straight ahead on law and crime daily
video captures the moment a suspect
takes aim at an ohio officer
how she was able to fire off five rounds
in response the pledio for a former
florida mayor
charged with shooting at a sheriff's
deputy the swat team member is speaking
out
over dale massage three-year sentence
he's dishonest he's a narcissist
and he has no conscience plus a former
pro football player is sentenced
to 14 years in prison for sex crimes
against five women
what keller winslow ii has to say after
his conviction and guilty plea
in the future i do plan to
tell my story law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a sheriff's deputy in ohio narrowly
escapes being shot
during a routine call and it was all
caught on camera
law and crimes angenette levy is here
with the video and what led up to it
yeah brian this video is pretty
incredible and we want to warn you
some people may find it disturbing this
happened back on february 15th
in a suburb north of cincinnati ohio now
take a look at this
the video you are watching was actually
recorded on a doorbell camera
it shows deputy sarah vaught approaching
a front door
she and other deputies were sent to
check on 56-year-old lance runyon
the video shows runyon opening the door
and firing toward deputy vaught who
ducked and fired several shots back
hitting runyon he was critically wounded
see if she'll give you the garage code
if she wants us to check on him
here he is
your hands
now deputy vaught then said i'm good
when her fellow warren county sheriff's
deputies asked her whether or not she
was okay
as you saw she was very fortunate she
was not hit by that gunfire
runyon faces charges of attempted murder
and felonious assault his first court
date has not yet been scheduled
because he is still in the hospital in
critical condition
brian fortunate indeed thanks angenet
joining us now is criminal defense
attorney imran ansari along with terry
austin
imran quick thinking saved this
officer's life
what do you think when you first saw
this video
well brian i think it was a welfare
check that quickly
escalated to something else and you know
i got to commend that officer
for her uh quick draw and her fast
thinking there
um it could have been a terrible
situation
uh we know that the suspect is
shot it's he's recovering and he's
charged for a crime which i think
uh clearly caught on that doorbell
camera
uh was something that could have been a
lot worse so
quick thinking on the behalf of the
officer now terry this went from
something very mundane a welfare check
to something terrifying and attempting
to murder in the blink of an eye how did
you react when you first saw the video
you know honestly brian my heart was
racing because i knew what was about to
occur so i was anticipating
thank goodness that deputy was alert she
was well
trained because we might have had a
different result
the really sad news here is this was a
welfare check
so what i'm thinking is that maybe there
was some mental illness here and what
i'm hoping
is that he gets the attention not just
medical
but maybe he does need some
psychological attention
as well absolutely we're thankful that
the officer is still with us an inch
there an inch there this could have been
a completely different story
a familiar face is now representing the
tiger king and is calling for him to
have a new trial
attorney in law and crime analyst john
phillips is taking up the appeal of
joseph maldonado passage
aka joe exotic exotic was convicted
of violating federal wildlife charges
and the murder for higher plot of his
rival
carol baskin he was vocal about wanting
to be pardoned
but did not receive one before president
trump left office
now it appears he's ready to launch his
appeal
we got a few calls and emails over the
pardon ultimately it led to joe emailing
us
and two weeks later about a hundred
emails back and forth so we're here
to meet with joe maldonado passage aka
joe exotic to determine whether we're
going to get involved with his case and
see what we can do to help him we are
honored to announce
that joe has retained our firm we're
going to seek a new trial
injustice in the criminal and civil
courts because we are committed to
justice
and committed to joe all right
we've gone from not guilty to pardon
from the president now to fighting for
an appeal
what kind of arguments would we expect
from a maldonado passage appeal
you know i think he's saying they're
committed to a new trial
basically a great ad because he's
committed to joe and if he's doing a new
trial here it means they have to show
either new evidence or that there was
some sort of
error or some sort of you know verdict
that was
against the weight of the evidence and
as it relates to the charges that
as the animals are concerned i think
he's going to try to say that
technically
they did not abuse the animals and as it
relates to the charges for carol king i
think he's going to try to say
that they were just joking and that they
didn't really intend
to kill her now imran you've represented
high-profile appeals
what would the game plan be if you were
lead counsel in this appeal
so brian i think it would be getting the
evidence that wasn't presented to the
lower court
and arguing that it should be presented
on a new trial
and we know that he intends to do that
he
has made a statement that there's going
to be footage
from the uh the hit netflix show
that was not aired that they're going to
rely on to present this case that his
uh trial was unfair and to get him into
court again
i think it's going to be really
interesting and what's really
interesting
is also that this firm also represented
the family
of carol baskin's ex-husband so you have
a lot of connection there and i think
it's going to be something that the
public
is going to be looking at intently just
like they tuned into the netflix stock
i mean i don't think the public or
myself are going to be able to look away
from this
all eyes are going to be on a potential
appeal and for that
i hope there is a new trial thank you
both and in other top legal
news involving celebrities rapper t.i
and his wife tiny
are denying sexual assault allegations
that span over 15 years
attorney tyrone blackburn has been
contacted by over 30 women
survivors and witnesses to the alleged
allegations
in a press release blackburn says that
clifford aka t.i
and tamika tiny harris kidnapped drugged
and raped the women in both georgia and
california
an attorney for the harrises released a
statement saying if the claims are
fairly investigated
no charges would be forthcoming the
statement went on to say
that the accusations are an obvious
attempt to misuse the justice system
it is unclear if either georgia or
california authorities have launched an
investigation
still ahead on law and crime daily
former nfler kellen winslow ii
is sentenced we'll bring you into the
courtroom to hear from his victims
but first the guilty plea of a former
florida mayor and those who disagree
with the plea deal
coming up
the suspect has been arrested he shot
our members
he's lucky he's not dead
lucky he's not dead that's how a sheriff
described a florida mayor
accused of shooting at deputies now that
ex-mayor is pleading guilty
dale mossad served as a mayor for port
richie florida until he fired on swat
team members
serving a search warrant on his home in
february 2019.
massage said he's shot in self-defense
not knowing they were law enforcement
mossad was accused of practicing
medicine after his license was revoked
investigators say assad is a known drug
dealer the state's governor removed
mossad
from office the next day now he's
pleading guilty to aggravated assault of
a law enforcement officer
in exchange for a three-year sentence
prosecutors agreed to drop attempted
murder charges
in a deal that some deputies are not
okay with
after that incident immediately
following i started suffering from
anxiety and stress
caused by it to have to go home and tell
my family after 20 years in law
enforcement
that i must died because a politician
decided that it was more important
to shoot the first cop that came to
arrest him then
then to lawfully surrender to the to his
arrest and to the warrant
i've had nightmares and i promise you
i'll never forget the image of him
standing at the top of the stairs
pointing that gun at
me and my team the fact that we're here
entertaining a plea deal
in a case where the defendant is accused
of intentionally willfully
knowingly shooting a firearm at law
enforcement officers during the
execution of a search warrant
is disgusting i'm appalled by it as a
person
as a citizen of pasco county and as an
employee of the sheriff's office
mr mossad has clearly exploited the
worst flaw
in the criminal justice system and
that's that money and political
influence buys you freedom if you're
rich
his conduct during the plea hearings and
during the interviews
during this investigation have
demonstrated that he is a true
psychopath
in court the judge agreed to mossad's
three-year sentence he's already served
about two years in jail
he'll also owe more than one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in restitution
for the record i just want to make sure
that it's clear that this was a plea
freedom worked out
between the state and the defense and
the court had nothing to do with this
because if i did i have to agree with
the sergeant
that mr massive is getting quite the
deal
i don't get involved in these plea
agreements i take these plea agreements
as long as they're legal and lawful
which this is
but mr mass and i want you to understand
that you're getting probation
to follow your prison sentence and
if you violate the terms of your
probation in a willful
or substantial banner you can still get
up to
10 years in state prison on a violation
here to break down the plea deal for the
former florida mayor is criminal defense
attorney imran ansari
and co-host terry austin terry three
years in jail for shooting at
officers is that the right offer to make
or should it have been more time
you know brian i think there should have
been more time this is one of the
lightest sentences
that i've seen for someone who attempted
to kill
a police officer here he could have done
that i think he should have gotten more
time and you know you heard there
that the judge who you know talked there
during the hearing said
that she thought that he should have
gotten more time and we know that the
deputies
who were on the stand they also thought
that he should have gotten more time so
i think that you know at the end of the
day because it was
a legal plea deal the judge let it stand
but he definitely got off light here
imran i know we both practice in
brooklyn and as a public defender if my
client gets offered three years with two
years already in
with this charge i'm telling him to take
it and run
is this a good deal for the defense
brian if you're looking at from the
defense standpoint
it's an exceptional deal he already has
two in
he's got one to go in one year he's
going to be out and you also have to
take the consideration that
um there's other aggravating factors
here after he was arrested
he tried to make a deal with the then
acting mayor of the town
uh to have someone quote pay for his
arrest
so his conduct even after he was
arrested for this crime
uh was not on the up and up so it is an
exceptional deal
it leaves me scratching my head and i
think it
also left the judge upset but she did
what she had to do under the law
and i'm sure that law enforcement crew
down there they're not happy about it
either
yeah it's interesting something smells
fishy there's got to be something in the
background that we don't know you don't
get these kind of offers
unless there's something that we don't
know about but we'll keep eyes on it
coming up on law and crime daily former
nfl tight end kellen winslow the second
case has come to an end
we'll tell you what his sentence is plus
as the nation prepares for the trial of
the first ex-cop charge
in the murder of george floyd his legal
troubles may not end there
when we come back
the trial for the minneapolis police
officer accused of murdering george
floyd
will start next week but federal charges
for derek shovin are also
possible law and crimes anjanet levy is
here to explain
you know brian there have been several
reports out there that a federal grand
jury is investigating george floyd's
death
that means that all of the officers
involved or maybe even some could be
facing federal civil rights charges
the video of george floyd's final
moments has been seen around the world
sparking outrage and calls for reform
former u.s attorney ben glassman says
it's a long-standing
policy of the department of justice that
state prosecutions move forward before a
federal prosecution
the idea is for the state or local
authorities to go first and if
that investigation and prosecution
sufficient to vindicate federal interest
then there's no need for a federal
prosecution
glassman cites two cases he handled
during his time as u.s attorney for the
southern district of ohio
the first corrections officer jason mize
pleaded guilty to using unreasonable
force while acting under the color of
law after throwing an inmate headfirst
into a concrete wall in 2016
the state prosecutor declined to charge
him mize is now awaiting sentencing
then in 2018 franklin township police
officer robert wells
kicked a handcuffed man in the head and
pleaded guilty to a federal charge
and went to prison in that case the feds
and the local prosecutor worked together
the investigations can be lengthy you
need to have
the federal agency go out and more
often than not re-interview every
witness
with an eye towards the elements of that
federal charge and then you have to
think about
are there other witnesses that you could
possibly investigate
and talk to that are related in the
wells case glassman says that officer
lied about the use of force
federal civil rights cases aren't often
brought
the willful standard makes it very
difficult to prove these cases
it's a higher standard than just knowing
it's
essentially saying that the the
defendant violated the constitution on
purpose
like you knew what reasonable force was
and
even though you knew that you on purpose
used excessive force
but glassman says those cases can be
successfully prosecuted
these are cases that it's incredibly
important to bring if you are
pro law enforcement because officers
who commit these types of offenses
tarnish the badge
now ben glassman tells me that another
reason that these investigations can
take so long is because experts in use
of force are often consulted
and the agents investigating these cases
really have to take a close look at the
training these officers to receive
when determining whether or not the
force used is excessive and violates the
law
brian thanks angeannette be sure to tune
in to the law and crime network for
capital gavel coverage
of shroven's trial starting march 8th
when we come back
former nfl tight end kellen winslow ii
is sentenced for his multiple sex crimes
hear what his victims had to say after
the break
former nfl player kellen winslow ii was
sentenced to 14 years in prison
for a series of rapes and a slew of
other sex crimes
the now 37 year old was supposed to be
sentenced in march of 2020
but that was delayed due to kova 19.
winslow was convicted for raping a 58
year old homeless woman
in 2019 as well as indecent exposure and
a lewd public act
he was going to be retried on sex
felonies including the 2003 rape of a 17
year old but he later pled guilty before
standing trial
mr wenzel has taken so much from me that
finally being able to point him out
and make it here what he's done makes me
feel empowered
and that every victim should know that
they have a voice as well
i feel that with everything that mr
wenzel has done she should be sentenced
before
14th it may not be like but at least we
can keep them away from harming anyone
your honor i was so scared when he raped
me
that every black jeep that drove by
might be him
i was scared to go outside not knowing
who it was
i can't believe he could be so nasty it
really hurt my feelings that he took
advantage of me
he scared me so bad knowing now that he
was my neighbor
and i couldn't believe that a nfl
football player would take advantage of
me
i hope that you serve the 14 years and
it really impacts your life
if you ever come out i hope you get the
help that you need
in sign jane doe one
winslow's attorneys say that the one's
highest paid tight end in the nfl
suffers from traumatic brain injury from
playing football as well as the
motorcycle accident
which ended his career his
removal from the nfl is not his
inability to play in the nfl caused him
to drop into a deep deep spiral of
depression and anxiety and as a result
he saw medicated through alcohol
pain medication spice marijuana whatever
you can get a hold of
but that was his way of self-medicating
the reason all that is important
is it kind of dovetails into the old
thing in the room which is cte
we felt we felt that he's probably had
head injury at least a
thousand times and i think that the
conduct in this particular case
is supportive of this finding of cte or
potential cte
we know that cte can only be found when
the person is dead
in an autopsy but we can look at
symptoms
but he committed those crimes in 2003
before the nfl career
and before he suffered as you say the
thousand blows to the head
so it just leaves us with um
someone who can only be described in two
words and that
is a sexual predator and that's what
kellen winslow the second
is he's a sexual predator he
he preys on vulnerable victims and uh is
very brazen in the way he carries out
his crimes
back one last time to discuss the
sentencing of kelling wounds oh the
second is imran ansari
and terry austin during the sentencing
you just heard it the defense attorney
said
that winslow the keller winslow ii sorry
suffer from ct
could that have an effect maybe down the
road for some sort of an appeal
well brian you know that this condition
cte which is a essentially a traumatic
brain injury that
uh one develops um after repeated blows
to the head and here
uh it presents itself in football
players that was given as a reason
prior uh to the sentencing and i think a
22-page report that was filed with the
court last year
where the defense provided the court
with
uh medical evidence to show um how this
injury a traumatic brain injury can lead
to behavior
consistent with how winslow exhibited in
such as impulsive or erratic behavior
even to the degree of committing sexual
assault
so we have it here it's a negotiated
plea i don't think there's going to be
any appeal
but it was definitely used by the
defense in order
to mitigate the exposure for winslow um
in the sentencing phase uh and whether
that had an effect well
you know we see here that he has a
sentence which he was facing
life in prison here we have an assist a
sentence that was negotiated
and cte was a big part of that i believe
now tara we know with taking this plea
there's going to be no second trial
was this a right move considering the
victims don't need to take the stand
again
this was absolutely the right move
because these women will be spared
having to
testify again and we know that that was
very difficult for them
thank you both for joining us and thank
you for joining us here on crime daily
we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you